vasile tatouage is a young ukrainian
customs officer and an improbable symbol
of hope for his country in july he took
over the to such a point on the
Ukrainian Hungarian border
across the bridge is European Union
Territory that's precisely what makes
tusa attractive to smugglers so
attractive that it costs at osha's
predecessor his job he was accused of
cooperating with the smugglers in other
words of corruption now it's up to
totosh to prove himself they ship the
Swedes and that cigarettes are the most
frequent contraband edit from the
Ukraine into the European Union the
smugglers and their accomplices turn
enormous profits because cigarettes are
a lot cheaper here than in the EU little
bit enemies resonates opinion about the
smugglers methods are many and cunning
cesta Tosh and just a few examples are
displayed on the custom offices trophy
wall often the cigarettes are smuggled
into the EU by the pallet full literally
the packs are actually hidden inside the
pallets the Chad let off a fake we're
living in the 21st century there are all
kinds of ways to smuggle thanks some
hunters forge papers others try to sneak
goods through customs in freight
shipments tiwari 01 tells you the
borders of three EU member states run
through the Carpathian Mountains in West
Ukraine Hungary Romania and Slovakia on
the one side is the comparatively
well-off EU and on the other the abject
poverty and youth unemployment of
Ukraine the Carpathians are one of
Ukraine's most beautiful regions but in
early July the tranquility was shattered
by the sound of gunfire in broad
daylight just a few kilometers from the
border in the town of mukachevo in the
Carpathians
fighters of Ukraine's right sector
paramilitary group opened fire and then
fled into the mountains with Ukrainian
security forces on their heels these
images were seen round the world
suddenly checkpoints were popping up in
West Ukraine like those in the East the
media spoke of a second front opening
inside the country Sergei roshni ankh is
a former mayor of the town of Garad on
the border of Slovakia he says the
right-wing extremists are just after a
bigger cut of the smuggling profits
that's what the shooting was about to
get all good he shows the camera team
his country house a former military
facility as mayor he got to know the
area and where the choice properties
were okay a truck full of contraband
from Ukraine to the EU costs 150
thousand euros in paola and another 90
thousand in Hungary which makes two
hundred and forty thousand euros in all
for that they'll turn off the big
scanner for five minutes this year was a
prob it's a business expense that pays
off from tuza the cigarettes are
distributed throughout the EU
the young customs head commissioner
Vasya Tosh is not discouraged we'll
never be able to win the fight
completely nobody can but we're doing
everything we can to put an end to the
smuggling sales up in it it's a ray of
hope in Ukraine one of Europe's most
corrupt nations